Guten Morgen Linus.
Guten Morgen Linus. Guten Morgen, Tim.
Endlich wieder in der Metaebene vereint.
Ja, mit äh ordentlichen Kopfhörer jetzt auch auf deiner Seite.
Genau, endlich wieder mit ordentlicher äh Qualität. Das war ein kleines Desaster und äh ich habe auch schon Vorkehrungen getroffen, dass es so nicht wieder passieren wird. Mal schauen, äh ob ich mein Wort halten kann,
Ja, aber ähm,
Es gibt wieder einiges zu berichten und wir haben uns äh diesmal auch noch äh Verstärkung äh dazugeholt. Ähm unseren ähm Gastkommentator. Unser Gast Kommentator Gregor, hallo Gregor.
Hallo Tim, hallo Linus. Hi, das wollte ich schon immer mal sagen.
Du musst guten Morgen sagen.
Na ja, passt schon.
Denke auch, das passt schon. Die Wahrheit ist auch immer ein guter Einstieg.
Ja, das passt schon. So und wie wie kam es, wie kam es äh äh zu der Idee hier noch einen Hausphilosophen dazuzuladen.
Der Hausphilosoph und ich haben gestern ein Bier zusammen getrunken.
Netzpolitisches.
Ein netzpolitisches Bier, ähm.
Ja, in in der von mir favorisierten Raumstation.
Ja, der in der Seaways Berlin, wo gestern der äh dritte netzpolitische Abend der Vereins digitale Gesellschaft,
und ähm da das ja, wie Gregor gerade schon sagte, seine favorisierte Raumstation ist und weil der Netzpolitisch interessiert ist, weil er selbstverständlich dort, genauso wie ich und dann haben wir uns ein bisschen unterhalten.
Das stimmt nicht so ganz. Ich wollte jemanden von der auch sprechen. In einem ganz anderen Zusammenhang.
Ja und jetzt äh sitzt er hier. Ich will dir da nicht losgeworden und da habe ich gesagt, ja komm, kannst du auch mal einen Podcast.
Ach ja.
Nein, wir hatten ein interessantes Gesprächsthema, interessante Impulse und da haben wir gesagt, dass äh die bereiten wir nochmal äh vor Publikum aus.
Ja und ich bin ja ein großer Fan der, wie heißt die Sendung Nord Netzpolitische Um.
Vornetzpolitik.
Logbuch Netzpolitik.
Genau, Logbuchnetzpolitik, so heißt das hier und wir feiern die neunzehnte Ausgabe und äh ja
Äh ich fand das auch sehr angemessen, weil sich auch in dieser ganzen netzpolitischen Debatte jenseits der der Neuigkeiten irgendwie in zunehmenden Maße auch interpretierungswürdiges äh einschleicht.
Und das wird heute sicherlich auch nochmal zur Sprache kommen, aber einsteigen tun wir erstmal mit einer Überraschung.
Ist wieder da.
Ist wieder da. Das hat ja nicht lange gedauert, ne?
Ich weiß gar nicht genau, wann es abgeschaltet wurde,
äh ich glaube irgendwann noch in den neunziger Jahren, nachdem es irgendwie fünfzehn Jahre lang aktiv war, äh das analoge Mobilfunknetz, was wir früher hatten, CTEL
Große Autotelefone waren das, ähm wo dann irgendwann durch die D-Netze überlebt,
Und jetzt äh seit die Telekom seit zweitausendsechs haben die nicht mehr die Markenrechte daran und jetzt gibt es einen Netzpolitikverein aus dem Kreise der CDU, der sich deswegen diesen Namen aneignen konnte.
Passt ja auch. C wie Zukunft und dann halt Netz.
Netz.
Gegründet so im Umfeld oder zumindest der Vorstand besteht jetzt aus Peter Tauber und Thomas,
Beide Namen sind wahrscheinlich hier beim Lokbuch auch schon mal gefallen. Das sind, sagen wir mal, in der CDU diejenigen,
die nicht mit absoluten Hardliner-Positionen auffallen. Allerdings sind's halt immer noch CDU-Mitglieder.
Also ich glaube, die Namen sind hier noch nicht gefallen. Da ist.
Schon. Ja, Zombeck habe ich attestiert, dass man sich mit dem wenigstens unterhalten könnte. Ähm Peter Tauber ähm habe ich das noch nicht attestiert, deswegen ist der Name wahrscheinlich hier auch noch nicht gefallen. Ähm.
Weil du es eben nicht existieren kannst oder.
Er hat bis jetzt mich nicht davon überzeugen können, dass man sich mit ihm unterhalten könnte. Ähm,
das ist aber ein anderes Blatt. Wir hatten mal einen kleinen,
Anrempler. Na gut, kann man auch erzählen. Und zwar, weil's die, als der Verein digitale Gesellschaft gegründet wurde, der nämlich ja ziemlich auch ungefähr vor einem Jahr gegründet wurde, da war Peter Tauber einer derjenigen, die da äh,
am größten drauf gefeuert haben, dass jetzt irgendwie was, dass sich da jemand anschickt ähm,
ohne äh ohne demokratische Legitimation sich irgendwie in die Politik einmischen zu wollen oder was auch immer. Also der,
der ist einfach ähm der sehr, sehr hat da in meinen Augen relativ frei gedreht und dann auch auf allen Podien sich da irgendwie hingesetzt und ja jetzt hat er ein Jahr später seinen eigenen Verein gegründet und,
damit das äh auch irgendwie also dieser Verein ist eben jetzt sehr, sehr klar in der in die Partei verwurzelt, ne? Es gibt ja eigentlich diesen, also digitale Gesellschaft, der,
immer wieder häufig den Grünen zugeschoben wird, weil es irgendwie mehrere davon,
auch Mitgliedschaft bei den Grünen haben. Da ist aber zum Beispiel auch mit Jonas Westphal, der netzpolitische Sprecher oder was der äh SPD-Fraktion. Nee, im Moment ist ein völlig,
ähm.
Also beileibe nicht nur Leute, die den Grünen zugeschrieben werden kann und vor allem ist das Selbstverständnis der digitalen Gesellschaft nicht zu den Grünen, zu gehören oder einen Zink-Tank der Grünen zu sein.
Überhaupt nicht. Also Jonas Westfal ist Sprecher des Forums Netzpolitik der Berliner SPD. Äh ist da zum Beispiel drin, ich bin ja seit jeher überzeugt niemals einer Partei,
zugerechnet werden zu wollen aber OK sagen wir mal,
Gesellschaft irgendwie so in Richtung der Grünen gedrückt, auch wenn wir von Beauty irgendwie als verleumdere Arschlöcher bezeichnet werden. So dann, dann kam ähm.
Hatten wir ja letztes Mal erzählt.
Na ja, das ist ja eher ein Ausweis, dass sie als Parteifreunde quasi schon akzeptiert seid.
So geht man doch mit einem politischen Gegner nicht um.
Genau und dann dann kam ja ähm D vierundsechzig
wo dann ähm auch sage ich mal die SPD-Nähe irgendwie vertreten war. D vierundsechzig hatte sich ja dann schon etwas konkreter auch wirklich auf die SPD bezogen, waren aber immer noch keine Leute mit drin, die jetzt irgendwie,
Positionen groß bekleiden bei der bei der SPD, also zumindest nicht an an vorderer Front des Vereines,
Und ähm jetzt kommt eben die CDU mit dem Zähnetz äh daher und die haben also wirklich eine relativ klaren relativ klaren Bezug. Ja, ich meine, das sind die beiden Leute, also sowohl Peter Tauber als auch,
Thomas Jetzhomberg sind, wie gesagt, in der Enquete-Kommission für die CDU, CSU,
und ja, wollen jetzt da irgendwie so ein, haben jetzt so ein Bündnis gemacht, irgendwie Dorothee Bär haben sie, glaube ich, auch noch dabei und,
im Prinzip sagen wir mal 'ne wahrscheinlich ist das gar nicht so schlecht dass es das gibt weil,
wirklich so auf den ersten Blick von den Namen, die ich da erkenne, dass die Personen sind, die wahrscheinlich eine etwas progressivere Haltung innerhalb der,
CDU haben.
Ähnlich wie das äh wie man das bei D vierundsechzig äh sagen könnte, dass das eben auch die progressiveren oder zumindest die Vorratsdatenspeicherungsgegner
In der SPD sind, die sich da versammelt haben, gut Vorratsdatenspeicherungsgegner ähm findet man dann in der CDU dann,
nicht nicht direkt. Also ich habe da mal ähm nochmal genauer draufgeschaut, welche Position es da so gibt. Ähm aber ja, haben sich also hat sich gegründet ähm existiert.
Tja, schön.
Ich habe da mal eine Frage, hm bist du sicher, dass sich die erst vor einem Jahr zur Republika ähm gegründet hat oder ist das nicht schon zwei Jahre her.
Achso, ja, diese reine Gründung ist ja irgendwie viel länger her, aber genau diese Bekanntmachung war.
Diese aus dem Shitstorm geboren.
Ja, der der Phönix aus dem Shitstorm, also ein Shitstorm ist ja Shitstorm, es muss ja einfach ohne Shitstorm ist ja nichts mehr. Äh Internet hat ja nur noch Shitstorm. Wieso wie sollen wir unterhalten werden, wenn nicht irgendein äh wenn's keinen Shitstorm gibt? Also ich.
Public Relations ist heute die Generierung von Shitstorms.
Anders konntest du doch nicht niemals in die. Ähm genau, aber digitale Gesellschaft hatte sich ja irgendwie früher gegründet. Ich war ja bei der Gründung auch gar nicht dabei. Ähm so, aber jetzt gibt's eben die Bekanntmachung.
Ich, ich, ja gut, ich ich frage mich jetzt, was jetzt die Funktion von Zähne sein soll. Ich meine, das ist ja,
relativ klar noch klarer glaube ich als jetzt bei D vierundsechzig eine Positionierung im Parteienkontext und kann von daher ja eher als Arbeitsgruppe der CDU CSU angesehen werden, als jetzt wirklich eine
unabhängig arbeitende Organisation, ja. Ja. Das äh von daher, also der Vergleich mit der digitalen Gesellschaft, der,
fällt mir da schon äh recht schwer, ne.
Also ich wollte genau das wollte ich gerade zeigen, dass eben dieser Vergleich nicht wirklich gemacht werden kann. Also genau da das wollte ich eigentlich mit dieser Entwicklung oder diesen Unterschieden auch herausarbeiten, dass dieser ähm dass dieser Vergleich.
Herkunft ist einfach eine andere, das hatten wir ja auch schon bei D vierundsechzig im Prinzip genauso. Jetzt scheint's aber so ein bisschen zum Trendsport zu werden für jede Partei äh da noch eine Netzgruppe zu gründen. Ich freue mich, wann die Linken äh dann endlich mal an den Start gehen oder haben die schon was?
Die haben oh wie heißt das denn?
Aus Kranitz.
AG Netzpolitik oder sowas?
Das wird eine sehr alberne Sendung heute. Ich glaube, wir hatten das sogar schon beim Thema D vierundsechzig ähm schon mal angesprochen. Was jetzt grad selber auch nicht so genau. Wir schlagen das mal nach,
Dafür haben wir ja unseren eigenen Podcast.
LAG Netzpolitik, Landesarbeitsgemeinschaft, Netzpolitik der Partei, Die Linke in Berlin, okay, in Berlin nur, ja.
Ja gut, das äh hat sich dann nicht so klanglich äh herausstehenden Namen gewählt.
Nee, aber die haben dann zum Beispiel so diese Netz für alle Konferenzen, die haben da also haben auch irgendwie so eine Kneipe, aber irgendwie sowas so ein big Player, wie Zähnez.
Nur die Piraten hinkenken noch hinterher.
Den Piraten, ja, Sascha Lobert twitterte das ja, die Piraten haben's versäumt, ja, jetzt hat sogar die CDU hat vor dem Piraten-Internetverein ja, wie stehen die jetzt da?
Jetzt muss man sich also wenn man sich das denn so anschaut, wie was was soll, was will diese Szene jetzt? Ja, wofür stehen die? Also sagen, wir wollen eine bürgerliche und verantwortungsvolle Netzpolitik, fairen Ausgleich zwischen den unterschiedlichen Interessen ähm,
wollen die Werte mit Leben füllen, Respekt und Toleranz im Umgang miteinander, also irgendwie wieder relativ komisch, ne? Ähm,
dann fangen sie irgendwie an wie die Freiheitsbegriffe irgendwie zu relativieren und so. Alles ein bisschen komisch, aber eben mit einer mit keine Beliebigkeit ohne Verantwortung.
Aber es wird jetzt auch erstmal nichts irgendwie abgelehnt, sondern das ist eigentlich nur so wolkige Reden.
Phrasen, die man so bei ihnen,
Wie man sie in diesen Bereichen hört, ne? Also ähm wie gesagt, das sind gemäßigte CDUler. Also wenn man so ja Zombies sagt irgendwie zur Vorratsdatenspeicherung ähm,
sieht er irgendwie differenziert, er hält es für falsch sämtliche Mails und Anrufe zu erfassen, fände es aber richtig IP-Adressen innerhalb eines vernünftigen Zeitraums zurückverfolgen zu können,
Tauber sagt ja er ist auch gegen die Vorratsdatenspeicherung weil die Rechte der Bürger nicht durch eine Verdachtlose Speicherung ihrer Daten eingeschränkt werden dürfen. Ähm,
aber also haben dann immer dann doch noch irgendwie so einen so einen Hang dazu, so aber ganz frei können wir das ja jetzt hier auch nicht machen, irgendwelche Sachen müssen wir dann doch machen. Ähm,
könnte das dann unter je nachdem wie weit sie dann gehen natürlich auch ähm jeweils in so einer Art Twistin, wenn ich irgendwie mal die Zitate zu Netzneutralität über Netzneutalität habe ich mit dem Herrn Beck schon öfter mal äh gestritten. Ähm.
Der sagt dann irgendwie so, ja ich bin absolut für Netzneutralität,
und ähm deswegen müssen wir die nicht gesellschaft äh müssen wir die nicht gesetzlich festlegen, weil dann äh wird Deutschland von Beamten überwacht,
und ähm,
Deswegen möchte er weniger Staat und im Moment gäbe es eben auch gar kein Problem mit der Netzneutralität und deswegen sollte man jetzt das Internet nicht nicht überregulieren.
Während man ihm dann gegenüber sitzt und sagte, doch klar haben wir Probleme mit Netzneutralität, ne? Schau mal hier, Beispiele und so. Ähnlich dann äh Peter Tauber, der sagt, äh ja hier ähm
muss ich irgendwie überlegen, ähm die Netzneutralität wird eben am besten durch den Markt hergestellt und im Moment ähm gäbe es da keine Probleme.
Ihr macht aber jetzt den Fehler, ihr guckt auf die Inhalte. Das ist vollkommen irrelevant. Äh Politik ist Organisation,
und diese D vierundsechzig und C Netz sind ein Symptom für den totale ähm,
Erklärung der Volksparteien. Dass sie nicht in der Lage sind, in ihren eigenen Strukturen und vernünftigen Dialog mit und über das Internet, über die Netzgesellschaft überhaupt noch zu organisieren,
und deswegen müssen die, die entsprechend das anerkannt haben, äh die ja gleichzeitig diesen innerparteilichen Kampf nicht mehr kämpfen wollen, haben sich ausgegliedert,
und das ist quasi schon der Anfang vom Ende.
Ja. Also es ist ja interessante These, ja, man könnte das ja auch äh etwas
positiver äh beleuchten, ja, jetzt werden da neue Akzente gesetzt und so die wie
widerstands äh Nester geben sich jetzt klangvolle Namen und versuchen damit äh innerparteilich halt äh die Bedeutung des Themas äh nach vorne zu rücken.
Ja gut, dann ist es halt wie ZDF und ZDF Neo,
Weißt, dass du quasi nur noch so Rentner hast, die ZDF gucken und es gibt keine Chance mehr quasi vernünftiges Programm innerhalb dieses Rentner Seniorentischs reinzubringen. Also musst du es ausgliedern in so ein Schnellboot.
Ja
Okay, ja, also äh ich denke, dass man sagen kann, also,
es ist auf jeden Fall irgendwie eine Reaktion, ne, auf irgendwie gesellschaftliche Veränderungen, auf irgendwie Piraten, Partei, Wahlen und irgendwie ein Eck.
Auf jeden Fall.
Eine Erkenntnis, dass man aber gleichzeitig mit einem Hans-Peter Ohl da oder was in einer Partei ist und dass da,
dass man jetzt irgendwie warten muss, bis die.
Was mich jetzt wirklich enttäuscht an dieser Initiative ist wirklich genau dieses dieses schwammiges Gefasel.
Was erwartest du denn von von CDUlern im Bereich der Netzpolitik?
Ja, gut, vielleicht will ich jetzt gar nicht sagen, dass ich da besonders hohe Erwartungen äh gehabt hätte. Ja, trotz alledem
gibt's auch auch bei diesen, ich weiß nicht, wie man die jetzt nennen soll, ja, sind das irgendwie nett, also Netzaktivisten sind es ja sicherlich äh äh nicht, ja, Netzpräsente vielleicht, ähm,
auch keine klare Wunschvorstellung,
Ja, also hier ist mehr so dieses, habt euch doch mal alle lieb und schreibt euch doch nicht so an auf Twitter und äh man muss das ja auch mal, also man könnte es,
wenn ich da jetzt versuchen würde, Negativen Spin reinzudeuten, könnte man auch sagen, es ist so so ein so ein bisschen so ein Beschwichtigungs äh äh Versuchen elaborierterer so nach dem Motto, ja na wer will kümmern uns ja auch drum und wir wollen ja auch Ausgleich haben und alles wird gut und lass uns mal machen.
Also in den Volksparteien gibt es ja immer auch so einzelne kleinere Fraktionen oder Plattformen, die bestimmte Spezial äh Interessen pflegen. Also die CDA
Arbeitnehmerschaft in der CDU, die Senioren CDU, dasselbe gibt es äh glaube ich auch bei der SPD. Wobei der äh,
Es gibt die Christen in der SPD, aber Atheisten in der SPD wurde ihnen untersagt, zu gründen.
Warum das?
Das ist Ressourcen die an der ganzen Geschichte.
Was ist denn das überhaupt für eine Rechtsstruktur? Also im Impressum steht ja Verein für Netzpolitik von e. V. Steht da nix.
Wahrscheinlich, weil sie in Gründung sind, ne?
Es soll also in der Satzung steht, soll ins Vereinsregister eingetragen werden. Ähm das ist ja in Berlin ein, ein das ist nicht besonders einfach, nee.
Dann setzen sie sich Zwecke. Das kann ich ihnen jetzt schon, soll ich ihnen das verraten, weil das diese,
kriegen sie zurück, ja? Also sie haben jetzt nicht irgendwie Zwecke gesetzt, Bewusstsein für den durch das Internet stattfindenden gesellschaftlichen Wandel stärken. Förderung der politischen Bildung und des demokratischen Diskurses,
im Rahmen der Digitalisierung, dass zum Beispiel ein äh gemeinnütziger Zweck,
Begleitung politischer Entscheidungsprozesse, zu netzpolitisch relevanten Fragen, die ökonomische Bedeutung der Digitalisierung unserer Welt zu vermitteln. Das ist natürlich, ich meine, da da muss man ganz klar sagen, da haben,
Peter Tauber und äh Thomas, ähnlich wie Jimmy Schulz, durchaus ihren Fokus, ne? Ökonomische Bedeutung. Das äh,
sehen die durchaus. Also die haben große Sorge, was irgendwie das Abhängen ähm der deutschen,
irgendwie internationalen Vergleich auf diesen Markt äh angeht und auch natürlich äh Berücksichtigung mittelständischer Unternehmen und so. Und das haben sie jetzt auch hier als Zweck des Vereins,
was das Problem wird sein, dass sie da nur einen haben, der irgendwie als gemeinnützig gilt und deswegen werden sie das zurück.
Das sind davon die Rede, dass das ein gemeinnütziger Verein ist.
Das ist dann Paragraph drei der Satzung, dass sie äh gemeinnützige Zwecke irgendwie äh.
Meinst du, das kommt so nicht durch?
Naja, bei uns war's ja irgendwie die Förderung von Grund- und Freiheitsrechten, ist kein gemeinnütziger Zweck,
Das war ja die Antwort bei digitaler Gesellschaft und da gibt's im Prinzip kriegst du quasi gibt's 'n Gesetzestext, da sind diese sechs mögliche gemeinnützige Zwecke und die musste dann einfach übernehmen. Da muss halt Copy paste machen,
sonst bist du nicht gemeinnützig.
Stoppen die Zeit wie.
Wenn du alle sechs nimmst, dann sind's zu viele, ist auch nicht in Ordnung. Also da muss man sehr geschickt vorgehen.
Ist flauschig nicht auch irgendwie gemeinnützig.
Musst du erst noch führen.
Wir stoppen auf jeden Fall die Zeit und gucken mal, äh wann sie ihre Satzung durch haben und was dann am Ende davon noch übrig bleibt.
Satzungen, Satzungen her, also ähm,
Ich denke, der der wahre Vereinszweck, den hat äh Gregor da ja schon durchaus besser erkannt, als das jetzt vielleicht in der Satzung steht, ne. Ähm interessant ist natürlich auch, äh was wir jetzt noch gar nicht angesprochen haben, wer da sonst noch so drin ist. Ich meine, Erika Steinbach.
Ja? Äh.
Wird von mir oft durchgefavt auf Twitter.
Ja, es ist bei Twitter es immer noch nicht ganz klar, ob das jetzt einfach der erfolgreichste Fake-Account ever ist oder ob die wirklich twittert.
Gibt's denn irgendwo eine Mitgliederliste? Also ich sehe sowas nicht.
Es gibt irgendwie unter äh mitmachen.
Da drunter irgendwie hundertvierzig Zeichen für das C-Netz und da stehen dann irgendwie Namen, wer da irgendwie bei ist. Aber so richtig äh.
Aber da keine Erika Steinbach.
Ja, ich weiß auch nicht genau, wo das herkam, dass sie da drin ist. Ähm.
Also, gibt ja einen Antrag auf Mitgliedschaft. Äh schön als PDF, ja. Das kann man dann ausdrucken. Das ist auch sehr wichtig und.
Auf jeden Fall hat die CDU jetzt quasi auch eine E-Mail-Adresse oder ein Twitter-Account, an den man von der Netzgemeinde her, an die CDU auch quasi mal herantreten kann, die nicht Peter Altmaier heißt,
Das ist ja schon auch.
Aber wo habt ihr denn diese Information her, dass Erika Steinbach äh.
Bei Golem, bei Golem steht's. So, äh Peter Altmaier äh ist auch Mitglied da.
Also, das ist der Nestor dieser Gruppe, würde ich mal sagen.
Ja. Peter Altmaier, Dorothee Bär, Dagmar Wöhrl, Erika Steinbach, Präsidentin des Bundes der Vertriebenen.
Man wolle natürlich auch nach außen wirken, vor allem aber die netzaffinen Mitglieder von CDU und CSU sammeln.
Ich sehe uns als Trainingslager an, sagt ja Zombeck. Also ins Bootcamp gehen die da,
es es gehe nicht darum Parteimitglieder ins Netz zu erklären, allerdings spielt dieser Gedanke bei der Gründung wohl eine Rolle,
Ähm und es gäbe natürlich viele äh skeptische Menschen und so weiter. Ich meine, die sind auch in einer schwierigen ähm Position da in der CDU. Ich meine, wenn du wenn du mit solchen Positionen wie wie sie die haben ähm,
Selbst mit denen irgendwie alleine stehst, ja?
Also bei der Vorratsdatenspeicherung relativ ab relativ in Richtung Abwägen und ja, wir müssen alles berücksichtigen mit anderen Worten, wir müssen Grundrechte einschränken. Ähm bei der Netzneutralität dann so auf Seite des Marktes. Es sind ja schon eigentlich
ähm ja, das sind ja Positionen, die schon irgendwie eben auf eine relativ starke Einschränkung des Netzes setzen und mit denen sind die immer noch der CDU zu.
Aber kennt ihr den London? Das ist so ein Gedächtnisrennen für äh die Aufhebung, das vor einem Automobil ein Mensch mit einer roten Laterne vorweglaufen muss, um die Hühner zu wahren, dass jetzt ein Auto kommt.
Und als diese Regelung gefallen ist, war das natürlich ein großer Tag für die Automobilisten. Jetzt müsst ihr euch quasi vorstellen, diese.
Hundert Hühner bald raufgegangen oder was.
C, dieses Zenetz, das ist gewissermaßen Leute, die sind wie Automobilbesitzer in einer politischen Struktur, wo alle dafür sind, dass weiterhin aber die rote Laterne geschwenkt wird.
Und deswegen müssen die natürlich erstmal sich außerhalb organisieren, weil sie so eine revolutionäre Forderung haben.
Und äh deswegen haben die es auch wirklich schwer.
Also wir vielleicht um es abzuschießen, wir wir sind sehr gespannt, was aus der Richtung kommt. Wenn die eine Wirkung in die CDU entfalten könnten, dann wäre der,
im Zweifelsfall der CDU einen Gefallen getan und unter Umständen ähm da die CDU ja doch irgendwie immer in Regierungsnähe äh irgendwo verkehrt,
wäre damit im Zweifelsfall auch Deutschland eingefallen getan, ja? Wer jetzt nicht sagen, dass sie, dass deren Positionen sich hundertprozentig mit meinen Überzeugungen decken, aber meine Überzeugung
sind ja jetzt auch nicht das, ähm das Entscheidende. Sie sind auf jeden Fall äh,
könnten eventuell das Potential entfalten der CDU irgendwie.
Wir sehen das, glaube ich, genauso wie bei der D vierundsechzig. Wir warten jetzt erstmal, was äh Cocktailsatzsatz der Ankündigungen und Webseiten
Ähm D vierundsechzig hat ja äh vollmündig da große Konferenzen, Veranstaltungen und trallala angekündigt. Ich glaube bisher ist aber auch noch nichts konkreteres angekündigt worden oder
Zähne steht da jetzt nicht so sehr viel davon. Ähm wir warten mal ab, ja? Hundert Tage, dann kommen wir nochmal vorbei.
Ich glaube, auf irgendeinen Blogpost hatte er schon gesagt, dass dass man sich nicht an diese hundert Tage halten wollen würde.
So läuft das aber im Mediengeschäft. Ja, da.
Einen einen Tag vorm Kalender abreißen, ja.
Gut, weiter.
Ja ähm kurze Sache Österreich ähm nee, Österreich fangen wir Großbritannien machen wir, ne? In Großbritannien äh soll die Vorratsdatenspeicherung ausgebaut werden.
Also es gibt schon eine.
Ja, die haben ja sowieso ähm äh Großbritannien, ich meine die haben ja eine voll Videoüberwachung, der der Innenstädte, ja, also.
George Oval hat einfach voll Recht gehabt. Also so voll, ja. Das ist so, das ist wirklich krass.
Das ist, das ist wirklich krass, wobei ich äh er hatte da mal so eine ein lustiges Erlebnis in in,
London, das war ein ein sehr witziger Fahrradunfall, weil weil ich unvertraut bin mit der,
mit, die fahren ja alle auf der falschen Seite. Und das hat dazu geführt, dass sich ein ein Fahrradunfall gebaut habe, der sicherlich sehr, sehr witzig war und ähm die,
diese Möglichkeit, sich dann dieses Video zu bestellen, weil man kann sich ja man guckt einfach kurz auf die Uhr.
Du hast einen Fahrradunfall gemacht, der sehr witzig war. Das war.
Der war unglaublich witzig. Es ist ja nichts passiert und und sah sicherlich sehr beknackt aus,
Und ähm dann haben wir äh gab es also tatsächlich die Möglichkeit, sich irgendwie für eine für eine jetzt nicht nicht kleine, aber immer noch bezahlbare Gebühr kann man sich dann so das Video holen. Ja, also da man.
Von irgendeiner Überwachungskamera, die es vermutlich gesehen hat.
Genau, dann guckt man irgendwie und sagt, ja, hier, wo war das ungefähr? Quasi nach deinem Fahrradunfall schaust du kurz auf die Uhr?
Und aber das waren dann irgendwie ich glaube vierunddreißig Pfund oder so und dann haben wir es am Ende doch nicht gemacht, aber äh das hat halt also dieses CC-TV ist halt auch eine Dienstleistleistung an dem Bürger, wenn er zum Beispiel einen witzigen Fahrradunfall baut und sich da noch,
das waren irgendwie.
Da auch so ein Plug-in, dass man das dann so gleich in die Facebook Timeline, wo man so langgelaufen ist oder so. Nee.
Laufen nicht. Es dauert wahrscheinlich auch Ewigkeiten, bis man das Video dann bekommt und dann ist es eh nicht mehr witzig.
Also auch dort muss man mal die historischen äh Grundlagen für diese extreme Videoüberwachung in London sich betrachten. Die kommen aus der Zeit des eher IRA-Terrors. Und das war,
schon richtig heftig,
weil die über in den achtziger Jahren äh doch relativ viel gemacht haben, zwar mit so einer gewissen menschlichen Attitüde immer so zehn Minuten bevor die Bombe hochgegangen ist, noch gesagt,
Liebe Leute, geht mal lieber raus, aber dann die Sprengwirkung war dann schon ziemlich fatal. Und interessant ist, dass sie quasi um den alten mittelalterlichen Wald,
In der City of London quasi entsprechend durch einen äh auch so mit Polizeihäuschen so eine richtige kleine innere Software gebaut haben, die sie dann auch mit diesem Videosystem äh abgegriffen haben, um einfach
Verdächtige Geschichte äh sehen zu können und deswegen gibt's da diese tausende Kameras schon seit den Achtzigern. Ne und dann ist es mal da
IAA ist weg, aber es kommen dann ja andere potentielle äh Gefährder, die man auch im Auge haben will.
Ja, der Islam.
Also es ist jetzt nicht so ein, dass der Brite an und für sich gewissermaßen anlasslos sich äh äh erstmal in diese Videoüberwachung gestürzt hat, sondern das ist ein ja, ein Beifang eines längeren Konflikts.
Naja gut, ich meine, das gibt halt äh ausreichend Bedrohungsszenarien, das stimmt schon, trotz alledem
gibt sich der der gemeine Brite der total Überwachung auch wirklich sehr frei hin das ist halt einfach so es gibt da verhältnismäßig wenig Widerspruch in der Gesellschaft dagegen es gibt nicht diese Sensitivität wie wir sie hier
in Deutschland äh kennen,
Was mich so ein bisschen, was ich halt von daher lustig finde, weil in Deutschland haben sie alle Angst vor dem Orwellstaat, ja, aber beschrieben wurde halt eigentlich,
England und, und, und, und genau da
sind einfach so viele dieser dieser Basisideen Überwachung drin, nicht weil hier auch die Kennzeichenerfassung und äh wenn du halt in die Stadt willst, et cetera, mit Mauts und, und, und, und all das, was ja
hier immer zumindest einen gewissen Widerstand erzeugt hat, das war da nicht. Aber was soll denn jetzt dieser Ausbau ähm,
Also was soll denn jetzt noch ausgebaut werden? In welchem Zustand befindet es sich? Und was kommt oder was soll hinzukommen?
Ähm also muss das vielleicht kurz zweitausendneun wollte die Labour-Regierung,
schon so 'ne so etwas einführen, dass sie also sagen wir wollen noch mehr
noch besser Kommunikationsdaten bekommen. Und zwar also sprechen wirklich einfach ja von Kommunikationsdaten und weisen darauf hin, dass er jetzt irgendwie,
die Leute nicht mehr nur über Telefone, nicht mehr nur über E-Mails kommunizieren, sondern eben auch Messenger, äh SMS
äh okay, SMS hatten sie schon, aber dann hatten sie ja zum Beispiel auch diese Zwischenfälle mit dem Blackberry Messenger. Wir erinnern uns, der war äh ganz kurz, ähm während dieser London Rights äh geriet
in Verruf,
Einerseits, weil behauptet wurde, dass die ganzen ähm Randalierer sich irgendwie mit äh verschlüsselten Nachrichten über den Blackberry-Messenger eben zum Plündern verabredet hätten,
gleichzeitig weil Research Emotion der Blackberry Hersteller dann zugegeben hat, dass das Ding nicht so verschlüsselt ist, dass sie es nicht,
Also es ist nicht Ende zu Ende Verschlüsse, hat Research Emotion gesagt, ja äh wir helfen der Regierung dabei, äh hier die Leute hops gehen zu lassen, ähm,
Und ähm also da gab's ja schon diesen Zwischenfall, also Blackberry Messenger, dann Social Networks, ähm,
Online-Gaming, steht hier jetzt auch, ich weiß nicht genau, aus welchem Grunde sie das meinen. Also es gibt.
Teamspeak.
Ach genau, ja, wenn man irgendwie World of Warcraft, die reden ja auch miteinander die Menschen, ne? So, also die Leute können auf sehr viele Wege irgendwie,
Das wäre sowieso der Plan für Terroristen, ja. Planen ihren Anschlag einfach bei World of Warcraft, ja. Über diese Mikrofone,
ich will ja keine Tipps geben. Geht sowieso in England nicht mehr, weil äh das wollen sie jetzt alles auch mit überwachen und da wollen sie jetzt ähm.
Na wenn du die Gegner und deine Angriffsziele so nennst, wie die Kampagnenziele im Spiel sowieso heißen.
Das ist.
So, jetzt ähm haben wir den haben wir ja David Cameron mit der Conservetive Party momentan da äh an der Regierung in England und die haben das jetzt wieder ähm haben dieses diesen Plan jetzt wieder aus der Tasche geholt,
und ähm jetzt gibt es da äh keinen noch keinen genauen ähm Entwurf zu, aber es ist eben angekündigt, dass sie sagen, hier wir wollen jetzt ähm,
ausweiten unsere Pläne, wer an Kommunikationsdaten,
und wie und ähm möglichst viel damit mit irgendwie ein,
mit mit äh mit aufnehmen. Ja, also Vorratsdatenspeicherung, wie sie irgendwie existiert, ähm reicht uns jetzt nicht. Wir wollen mehr.
Wir wollen mehr, also länger speichern oder mehr Daten.
Ja, also wie gesagt, zum Beispiel irgendwie eine eine Rechtsgrundlage dafür schaffen, dass sie effektiv irgendwie Facebook oder in solchen Systemen halt auch eine klare äh klar geregelte Prozesse dafür haben, dann einen schnellen Zugriff zu bekommen. Und,
Am besten live. Also irgendwie so eine so eine stellen sich wahrscheinlich so eine Art AP vor, wo sie dann, wo sie dann live da reinschauen können. Also sie haben.
Abhörschnittstelle in Teamspeak sozusagen.
Genau, haben wir jetzt also so so stellt man sich das jetzt vor. Es ist immer ein bisschen äh gefährlich über äh ungelegte Eier zu zu reden, ne. Also insofern, da gibt's keinen klaren ähm,
Entwurf bis jetzt, insofern ähm kann man jetzt nur sagen, dass es da dass die da offensichtlich in die Richtung planen.
Gibt's denn irgendeinen nennenswerten Widerstand? Ich meine, so mit diesen ganzen netzpolitischen Widerstand oder sonst wie freiheitsorientierten Widerstand in in England saß schon immer sehr mau aus. Ich meine, es gibt so International. Ähm.
Group.
Die Open Rides Group, aber ich hatte nie den Eindruck, dass auch nur irgendeine dieser Gruppen in England irgendeinen nennenswerte Bekanntheit oder einflussfährer erreicht hat,
täuscht das?
Ich wollte jetzt gerade mal schauen, es gibt natürlich irgendwie so eine.
Nicht unterstellen, dass ich komplett wirkungslos sind, aber das,
Ist immer ein bisschen schwierig mit Deutschland zu vergleichen, zumal wir die Situation hier sehr viel besser kennen, aber uns ist natürlich schon bewusst, dass äh unabhängige Gruppen hier sehr viel mehr Lärm erzeugen können in diesem Bereich, das er auch getan haben.
Also es gibt von der, von der Open Rights Group eine Petition ähm
Ich sehe da bis jetzt nicht, wie viele da mitgezeichnet haben. Es gab noch irgendwie eine andere. Also
ähm die haben da, doch genau, die haben da, glaube ich, innerhalb weniger Tage irgendwie vierzig bis achtzigtausend irgendwie Unterzeichnungen bekommen. Also da da wird sich jetzt, da bewegt sich schon etwas.
Da sind irgendwie Leute jetzt grade äh dran und machen da Petition, ich suche jetzt mal doch noch ganz kurz die Seite. Ähm also da regt sich auf jeden Fall Widerstand.
Wie breit der am Ende wird oder ob die das schaffen, da Einfluss zu nehmen, das weiß ich nicht genau.
Piratenpartei UK.
Auf Walisisch Plate, More Lader Wikipedia mit achthundert Mitgliedern aufgeführt.
Scheint auch noch nicht so den Durchbruch erlebt zu haben. Aber man hat ja auch gesehen,
Trotz der Sprachenbarriere in Europa gibt's gegenseitigen Einfluss. Wäre jetzt auch nicht so zu nicht sehr überrascht, wenn mal irgendetwas herüberschwappen würde, aber es scheint immer sehr schwierig zu sein. Das vom Kontinent, was auf die Insel rüberschwappt.
Also dieser Petitionstext, der dann irgendwie bei dot org dot UK irgendwie ähm
gehostet ist. Der hatte heute Morgen achtzigtausend
knapp achtzigtausend Unterschriften, sie versuchen jetzt heute noch irgendwie auf hunderttausend zu kommen der Petitionstext ist aber auch relativ kurz gehalten, bitte hören sie auf das Internet ihren,
Internet abzuhören oder so. Äh aber ich meine, in wenigen Tagen irgendwie achtzigtausend zu bekommen, ist schon mal ganz ordentlich.
Das ist jetzt aber so eine offene, unabhängig vom Staat geführte Petitionen.
Genau.
Netz.
Irgend so ein Ding. Habe ich auch schon unterschrieben.
Ja. Äh wollte ich auch gerade fragen. Ich meine, bei der bei den deutschen Petitionen ist es ja so, dass äh hat man ja das auch EU-Bürger da sich beteiligen dürfen. Ich frage mich, ob das hier auch in irgendeiner Form eine Rolle spielen.
Also bei irgendwie von irgendeiner NGO eine Petition, da spielt das natürlich keine Rolle.
Klar. Tja.
Also Vorschlag wird dann im Mai vorgestellt. Sie haben jetzt bekanntgegeben, dass sie daran arbeiten und ähm man darf gespannt sein in
in einem Staat, der sowieso schon irgendwie eine volle Überwachung und eine Vorratsdatenspeicherung hat, dass die sich jetzt noch hinstellen und noch mehr machen wollen, ist schon ähm
Das kann man mit mit sehr großem Staunen beobachten.
Ja, aber es ist ein Staat, wo der Einzelne, hm, Bürger, zum Beispiel, kein Ausweispapier hat,
Ja? Äh das ist ein Staat, äh der.
In in vielen, ne, ich wollte jetzt noch ein Beispiel äh bringen, dass äh mir jetzt aber gerade eben entfallen ist,
ich glaube, es ist wirklich die die europäischen europäischen Staaten sind in vielen Bereichen weiter voneinander entfernt, als man so oft im ersten Blick,
denkt und deswegen gibt es da solche ähm Probleme, weil es gibt so einen Nationalstaatsbegriff, der sagt, Nationen sind Erregungsgemeinschaften. Und äh,
Wenn die so unterschiedlich mental strukturiert sind, dann sind halt die Erregungsmuster und die Anlässe dafür sehr, sehr unterschiedlich.
Und ähm deswegen kann gewissermaßen,
Bestimmte, was in Großbritannien besondere Aufruhr erregt oder bei uns besondere Aufhol erregt nicht immer unmittelbar, selbst wenn man sagen würde, das wäre eigentlich gut und es wäre angemessen. Äh findet gewissermaßen so eine Schnittstelle
in dem jeweiligen politischen Aktivisten Lager. Ich habe das Gefühl, manches muss quasi erstmal über Bandel durch Amerika auf Europa kommen,
sowie Okopei hatte ich das Gefühl, einfach weil's in Amerika war, konnte und das so so einen allgemein Bekannter äh äh Flow ist von von, sagen wir es mal, ja? Ähm,
dass so etwas sowohl in Großbritannien als auch in Deutschland sofort äh in die eigene Kultur übernommen werden konnte. Weil man das schon immer macht.
Während wenn es irgendwie sonst wäre es nicht so gegangen. Okay
Was wäre denn jetzt, wenn äh Großbritannien jetzt irgendwie diese voll Überwachung da einführt und dann äh irgendwie international irgendwie Erfolge dann äh versucht vorzuzeigen oder vorzeigt in irgendeiner Terrorismus oder sonst was Bekämpfung? Äh das müsste wahrscheinlich dann leider nicht mehr über Bande
werden, ne? Dafür.
Ach so, genau das Problem, was ich noch sagen wollte, ist, äh Großbritannien hat ja auch keine keine Verfassung,
sondern das ist ein ein Konstrukt aus äh wie so ein so ein so eine äh brikulage, aus unendlich vielen Ausgefochtenen Kämpfen, mit einigen wenigen Grundsatz,
Entscheidungen ich glaube da ging's darum, dass der König ein nicht irgendwie äh unzweifelhaft äh äh vernichten darf,
äh
Es sind also äh so so ein paar äh äh ja, also quasi das durch. Ja, du ziehst das durch, griffst recht des des Staates wurde da mal so definiert. Und der Souverän in Großbritannien ist das Parlament.
Nicht das Volk,
Es ist hochinteressant. Also die haben gewissermaßen die Konzeption äh des modernen Staats, den wir haben, überhaupt nicht übernommen, sondern das Parlament hat sich gewissermaßen an die Stelle des Königs gesetzt,
Aber diese Souveränität nicht etwa an die äh äh an das an die an den einzelnen oder an die Gemeinschaft des äh Volkes weitergegeben,
Dadurch äh haben muss alles, was in Großbritannien passiert, äh auch im Parlament wirklich ausgefochten werden. Deswegen wollte wohl auch das auch gleich in die Luft sprengen.
Bei werden.
Ja, der Bogen schließt sich dann doch immer wieder. Na gut, wir werden das äh beobachten und begleiten und schauen mal, was da passiert. Ja, Abmahnungen.
Abmahnung, ja, interessant, also ich weiß gar nicht genau, woher dieses Thema jetzt so kam. Ich hatte das ähm,
ursprünglich gar nicht so unter dem gar nicht so eine Relevanz ähm,
beigemessen, Abmahnungen wegen offenen WLANs in Kaffees. Ja, also ähm,
Situation ist irgendwie klar, ne? Man möchte irgendwie Kaffee zu überteuerten Preisen verkaufen, man muss irgendwie dafür sorgen, dass die Leute da hier kommen ähm und wenn man denen irgendwie mehr als einen Kaffee verkaufen möchte, dass die da sitzen bleiben. Also sieht man zu, dass die WLAN haben, ja?
Und ähm dann ähm,
Schalte man das vielleicht nachts aus, damit damit diese ganzen Computer-Heinis irgendwann wieder gehen. Aber so Geschäftsmodell ist, ist relativ klar. Problem ist, dann kommen die da rein und machen irgendwie allen möglichen Quatsch im Internet,
und ähm dann gibt es Abmahnungen, ja, weil die äh eventuell oder so in deinem Cafe. Und ähm,
Im privaten Bereich gibt's da.
Gibt ja auch populäre Beispiele hier. Das äh.
Ich wollte den Namen jetzt nicht nennen, aber das Sankt Oberholz, ja, Rosenthal.
Schon sagen, ich meine, das ist ja nun wirklich bekannt wie ein bunter Hund und äh von daher auch äh populärstes Opfer der letzten Zeit, dass die sich halt jetzt lustigerweise einen anderen Provider gesucht haben, der dann sozusagen das Netz für sie betreibt, wo dann natürlich dieser äh,
extra äh Nervfaktor einer Loginseite mit Disclaimer und vielleicht, ich glaube, da muss man sogar einen eigenen Look sogar noch machen, also ne, dass man so einen persönlichen Bezug dann auf einmal aufmacht,
Und das Interessante ist, dass du dann, wenn die Firma das macht.
Die werden irgendwie nicht abgemahnt, ja.
Genau, dann besteht das irgendwie gleich auf anderen richtigen äh Basis und das ist an der Stelle ist es einfach sowieso schon mal totaler Quat.
Ne, der Witz ist ja bei den Gastwirten stets eigentlich auch nicht auf einer klaren rechtlichen Basis, weil also bei einer Privatperson haftet,
für ihren, für ihr WLAN. Das da gab's ja irgendwann schon mal das Urteil, hat doch mal einer irgendwie bis zu Ende durchgefochten. Ähm Privatpersonen ähm haftet, da gibt's ja dann auch regelmäßig irgendwelche Fälle, wo dann Rentner, die gar nicht wissen, dass sie WLAN haben,
weil es weil sie halt irgendwo eine Fritzbox mit einem offenen Netz hingestellt bekommen haben, als irgendwie der Telekom-Techniker kam, äh dann irgendwie Abmahnungen bekommen, ja? Die haben keinen Computer, aber ähm,
ähm jetzt gibt's natürlich im bei den bei den Gastwirten ist das eine etwas andere Angelegenheit. So sind die,
sind die Internetprovider, was machen die da? Wie ist das überhaupt zu bewerten, was sie da angeben, ja äh oder was sie da anbieten, ja, dass dass sie einfach jemandem Internet geben gratis als Service, wie ist das zu bewerten, sind sie dadurch ein Internet-Provider?
Oder was ist da genau, was ist da genau der richtige Sachverhalt? Das hat bis jetzt aber noch keiner zu Ende durchgefochten offensichtlich werden die einfach mit diesen Abmahnungen gegängelt,
und ähm jetzt im Sankt Oberholz, weil eben auch die Reaktion äh und die haben halt hunderte Leute, dass das Ding erstreckt sich über viele Stockwerke, hunderte Leute jeden Tag irgendwie im Internet hängen und die haben jetzt so einen nervigen Hotspot,
und äh diese Hotspot-Anbieter, ja, die haben ja offensichtlich dann wahrscheinlich irgendeinen Provider-Status, äh weiß der Geier.
Na ja, ja genau, weil die sind ja dazu verpflichtet, da neutral äh zu sein.
Ja, dabei, dabei könnten die wahrscheinlich, weil sie ihr, weil sie alles registrieren. Wahrscheinlich können die auch einfach die Nutzerdaten rausgeben,
Ja, da musste sie dich dann, bei denen musst du dich ja registrieren, mit mit irgendeinem, was weiß ich, im Zweifelsfall, äh wenn's irgendwie so ein Hotel zu Hotspot ist, vielleicht sogar auch irgendwie mit deine Kreditkartendaten,
Wie dem auch sei,
Abmahnungen offenen WLANs und da sind wir ja so ein bisschen, es geht natürlich bei diesen Abmahnungen dann um ähm äh,
um Geld mehr und ums Urheberrecht, ne. Also wir haben wir haben da eigentlich auch wieder so einen einen Schritt in Richtung äh Versuch des Versuchs irgendwie zu verhindern, dass die Leute,
Äh
dass die Leute irgendwie anonym im Internet sind. So, ich mein, was mit Internetcafes, ja, weiß ich jetzt gar nicht, warum ist jetzt da die Rede von von Kaffees, die Kaffee verkaufen, gibt ja auch Kaffees, die
kein Kaffee verkaufen, sondern primär Internet, was was wie ist die Lage bei denen, weiß ich jetzt einfach nicht. Vielleicht haben die entsprechend ähm klare, klare Regelungen dafür. Aber so man sieht irgendwie, es gibt ja gerade so wie.
Stellen ja meistens auf die Computer.
Ja und? Kann ich da trotzdem dann irgendwie äh was böses mitmachen? Irgendwas runterladen?
Na ja, weiß ich nicht. Vielleicht kann bitteren drauf, kannst du nicht installieren, lalala. Macht ja auch keinen Sinn, wenn's nicht dein Rechner ist et cetera, also das ist vielleicht auch nicht so ein großes Problem, aber wie sagt man so schön, im Internet eher nahe. Ähm Nudelloja.
Genau, also es geht auf jeden Fall äh irgendwie so in diese Richtung ähm zu versuchen, irgendwie zu verhindern, dass irgendwie Leute anonym im Internet unterwegs sind,
Ähm.
Und da kommen wir jetzt eben in dieses große äh in dieses große Themengebiet Urheberrecht, wo ich dann noch nur als kurze Meldung erwähnen wollte, dass es ja in in
Österreich seit längerer Zeit irgendwie diese Kunst hat Recht ähm Kampagne gibt, der irgendwie dann auch diese Gegenkampagne äh,
äh Kunst für Freiheit oder sowas entgegengesetzt wurde und ähm jetzt stellte sich irgendwie raus, ähm,
Ach so Kunst gegen Überwachung ist der, ist der.
Also Kunst halt rechts ist so diese äh fragwürdige Aktion, wo halt Autoren, Urheber irgendwelcher Art dann halt gesagt haben, ja hier
geistiges Eigentum, das alte Lied äh äh ja, wir müssen ja hier beschützt werden, kann ja alles nicht sein. Und jetzt ist herausgekommen,
Die Texte, die sie auf ihrer Webseite Plakate.
Auf ihre auf ihren Positionspapieren, auf ihrer Webseite sicherlich auch. Die haben also einen Forderungskatalog ähm und dieser Forderungskatalog deckt sich mit internen Papieren des,
Der International Federation. Und da stehen also die gleichen ähm Forderungen drin.
Also wortwörtlich. Mhm.
Wortwörtlich. Und jetzt ähm gibt's natürlich zwei Interpretationen. So entweder könnte man sagen, dass also diese Kunst hat recht, hat quasi bei der äh International Federation auf die Fotographic Industry ähm plagitiert,
Das wäre natürlich äh der Kampagne nicht zuträglich oder,
da stecken einfach die gleichen Leute hinter und da wird einfach 'ne große Kampagne gefahren, was ebenfalls der,
Oder eine eine Kampagne gefahren, wo noch einige Leute im Hintergrund hängen. Große Kampagne ist ja offensichtlich. Das wäre dann natürlich auch der Kampagne nicht wirklich zuträglich. Ähm.
Mehr kann man dazu eigentlich erstmal nicht sagen.
So viel kann man dazu nicht sagen.
War auf jeden Fall in der letzten Woche äh ein heißes Thema.
Ja
Auch in Deutschland haben wir nämlich jetzt sehr offensichtlich eine Graswurzelurheberrechtsbewegung beziehungsweise eine Rollrasenurheberrechtsbewegung. Ähm wie man eben, also Rollraden, Astrid,
Rollrasen, Astrid Turfing,
die äh der Begriff für eine gefälschte äh Gras-Roots-Bewegung.
Das ist ein toller Begriff eigentlich.
Astro Turfing. Und ähm,
Es begab sich, dass auf einmal einundfünfzig Tatort Drehbuchautoren einen Brandbrief irgendwie veröffentlichten auf der Seite des Verbandes der Drehbuchautoren,
Und äh irgendwie sich dagegen irgendwie relativ ähm relativ,
komisch irgendwie äh sagen, ja, wir wollen jetzt hier, äh haben jetzt einen offenen Brief, wir sind einundfünfzig Tatortautoren und ähm äh wir finden das irgendwie nicht gut, dass jetzt irgendwie alle sagen, ähm Urheberrecht müsse reformiert werden.
Und ähm so richtig die Argumentation dadrin, die kann ich jetzt auch gar nicht so wirklich wiedergeben, weil die auch so ein bisschen hin und her springt und ein bisschen wirr ist.
Das ist mimimi.
Ja Mimimi ist gut. Ich meine, die knallen unten noch eine Lebenslüge und Fakt ist, äh
und was ist überhaupt hier äh die Banilität der Rechtsverstöße wird kaschiert und hier zum Freiheitsakt hochgejezt. Also das das war schon ähm eine relativ äh krasse Formulierung, die.
Mimi, und.
Also was mich was ich mich wirklich frage, ist warum ausgerechnet Tatortautoren, also,
dass so Filme und Musik irgendwie weithin äh kopiert werden. Gut, aber dass so Tatort Drehbücher,
jetzt so das heiße Ergebnis sind so kurz nach dem Tatort am Sonntag und da irgendwelche bitteren Links durch die Gegend gehen hab ich jetzt so nicht gesehen also warum die? Und warum heizt die das jetzt so auf?
Hashtag Tatort ist eines der wichtigsten Twitter
Hashtags. Das heißt, wenn du die Tatortschreiber sich da an die Netzgemeinde melden, ist da schon mal sehr viel Aufmerksamkeit. Zweitens, sind sie sich natürlich äh äh sind es ja Experten für Verbrechen,
und Verbrechensbekämpfung.
Hat das einen ganz anderen Impact, als wenn jetzt die Autoren, das Autorenteam um Rosamunde Pilcher sich melden würde.
Und dritter Punkt natürlich eine der großen äh sage ich mal kulturellen Generationen übergreifenden Institutionen Deutschlands ist doch wohl der Tatort, ja?
Also äh ob man den jetzt als Student ähm in der Kneipe mit Kumpels guckt oder mit Opa und Oma äh eine Sache äh Tatort. Da kann man.
Fühlten die sich jetzt berufen, sich zu melden oder wurden die berufen, sich zu melden? Das ist so das, was was mir jetzt eigentlich im Kopf herum.
Das weiß ich aus einem Gespräch mit einer der unterzeichnenden Personen,
Das war also so, die sind alle in diesem, wie gesagt, man muss ja auch überlegen, wer hat den veröffentlicht, der Verband deutscher Drehbuchautoren. Und da sind die alle drin,
oder einige dieser Personen. So und dann kam offensichtlich eine E-Mail ähm,
von dem, ah, jetzt habe ich den Namen vergessen, aber derjenige, der das Ganze äh wahrscheinlich der erste Unterzeichner oder so oder ein Professor Doktor so und so, der da irgendwie auch mit drauf steht, der schickte also offensichtlich gezielt von diesem Verband aus,
An jene Mitglieder, die auch einen Tatort im Portfolio Portfolio hatten. Das heißt, bevor überhaupt da irgendwie so ein Brief geschrieben oder bevor die überhaupt informiert wurden, dass es einen solchen Brief gibt.
Ähm stand schon fest, wir wollen einen Brief der Tatortautoren,
und es stand auch schon der Inhalt fest. Die E-Mail, die dir nämlich bekamen, war, gerichtet an, ich glaube dann irgendwie etwas über fünfzig, ein paar haben auch gesagt, nee, ich schreibe da meinen Namen mal nicht drunter. Ähm,
ging also dann eine E-Mail an die und sagte lieber Tatort Autoren, wir haben hier einen offenen Brief ähm unterschreibt den mal. Oder bitte gebt uns zurück, gebt uns mal eine eine Antwort, ob ihr den unterschreiben wollt.
Und das haben die dann äh haben die irgendwie gesagt, ja ja, mach mal, ist schon ganz in Ordnung. Das heißt, da haben jetzt nicht einundfünfzig Leute am großen, runden Tisch gesessen.
Müssen wir mal was machen.
Oder oder irgendwie ein gehabt oder so.
Die wussten auch gar nicht, dass eigentlich nur nach Tatortautoren überhaupt gefragt wurde.
Das weise ich jetzt nicht genau, die Frage aber so so genau nicht gestellt ja? Aber es war also wirklich mein, kannst dir ja vorstellen, dass du jetzt nicht einundfünfzig Leute irgendwie äh an dem an dem an dem genauen Wortlaut dieses Briefes irgendwie gefeilt haben,
Ja, aber so der würde wohl quasi vorgeschrieben und dann mal zum Abnicken und äh einmal Select äh selekt äh Name from, Database, äh Portfolio,
Tatort. Und ähm zack, offener Brief,
ja? Und äh dann hat er natürlich immerhin diese Marke Tatort dazu nutzen, wenn man sich das nur mal so überlegt, natürlich treffen sich nicht einundfünfzig Tatorten irgendwie in der Kneipe und sagen, wir müssen jetzt mal einen offenen Brief schreiben,
Die wohnen ja auch irgendwie über ganz Deutschland verteilt. Und außerdem schreiben die ja nicht alle die ganze Zeit nur Tatorte. Ich meine, so ein Tatort, da schreibst du vielleicht äh mal einen, ja, wenn du jetzt nicht wirklich etabliert bist. Und dann kriegst du da deine äh so und so viel tausend Euro für,
ähm aber du bist ja nicht vom Beruf, du hast ja nicht auf der Visitenkarte stehen, Tatort, Drehbuchautor.
Also das war schon gut orchestriert. Wer immer das äh sich ausgedacht.
Eindeutig, ja. Eindeutig äh Orchestriert. Ganz, ganz, ganz offensichtlich.
Na ja es gab natürlich dann auch gleich den äh entsprechenden Gegenwind.
Ja, also erstmal ähm ist ähnlich wie bei Sven Regener schossen, dann überall die äh Blogartikel
aus aus dem Boden, ne, wo das alles falsch ist und das war in diesem Fall auch wirklich eine Sissi Phosarbeit, weil ähm da wir irgendwie an so vielen Stellen irgendwas aufgegriffen wurde, ich meine, obwohl es irgendwie ein ein formulierter,
Text ist, haben die dann noch mehr äh Knoten irgendwie, als als wenn Regener in einer undifferenzierten freien Äußerung, wo er einfach mal frei nach,
nach Laune gesprochen hat.
Was für Knoten?
Also ist wahrscheinlich also so so verdrehte äh Argumentation und irgendwie Lebenslüge und dann,
selbsternannte Problemlöser, wenn man Urheber und User besser stellen will, braucht es ja einen, der diesen alle haben, wir alle, alle haben alle wieder lieb, Kompromiss, bezahlt und und irgendwie also so völlig.
Also irgendwie so so das ist ja kein Argument, also,
Wer redet davon, dass da irgendwie einer was bezahlen muss? Es geht ja davon, äh es geht ja hauptsächlich wird ja dafür argumentiert, dass die User die Urheber direkter äh vergüten, sodass mehr Geld bei den Urhebern ähm landet. Man will ja eigentlich die,
die Stärke der oder die Position der Urheber stärken gegenüber den Rechte Verwertern
und ähm auch hier ist natürlich wieder dieses große Problem, dass äh Urheber- und Verwertungsrechte andauernd in dieser Debatte gleichgesetzt werden.
Ja, interessant fand ich hier so die die Adressaten, ja? Also es wendet sich ja schon in der ersten Zeile an die liebe Grüne, liebe Piraten, liebe Linke, liebe Netzgemeinde,
Also ja, schließt das dann auch Peter Tauber mit ein, ja? Frage ich mich jetzt, so das Zehn-Netz, die gehören die eigentlich dann auch zur Netzgemeinde.
Haben sich deswegen schnell noch gegründet.
Wir wollten auch angesprochen sein,
Ja, also es ist schon wirklich absurd.
Ja und dann also es geht schon irgendwie los, dann irgendwie ähm diemagogische Suggestion, es gäbe keinen freien Zugang zu Kunst und Kultur mehr. Äh,
Also komm, äh auf jeden Fall, dass diese diese Argumentation war soz so verworren, dass selbst die Antwort des CCC ähm der ist ja eigentlich,
Da kamen dann die einundfünfzig ähm Hacker,
äh die sich zusammengesetzt haben und den Tatort Drehbuchschreibern in einem offenen Brief geantwortet haben, der war nicht viel kürzer.
Kürzer, Venedig oder da haben sie sich auch, glaube ich, mal voll ausgetobt, ne?
Ja, aber also es war auch leider so, man musste da wirklich so viel aufgreifen an an irgendwelchen Satzfetzen, die in diesem Tatort drüben. Das wäre als als Drehbuch hätte man dann hätte man diesen Brief niemals irgendjemanden verkauft,
Aber interessant ist natürlich wirklich diese,
Äh Sache, dass es orchestriert ist, ne, dass irgendjemand sagt, der hier verbannt der Drehbuchautoren, schnapp mal deine besten Pferde im Stall. Das sind die mit Tatort,
die haben die beste Wirkung, ja? Ähm gut, man hätte jetzt vielleicht auch irgendwie die Drehbuchautoren der erfolgreichen deutschen Kinofilme nehmen können, aber ähm,
Marke Tatort ist da sicherlich doch noch um einiges stärker,
Als die deutschen Kinofilme auf jeden Fall gucken, jeden Sonntag Abend mehr Leute äh Tatort als als je irgendwie ein deutscher Kinofilm an Reichweite erreicht oder selten.
Kann ich jetzt so direkt nicht miteinander vergleichen, aber wie auch immer äh.
Ein erfolgreicher deutscher Kinofilm erreicht vielleicht zwei, drei Millionen.
Richtig nach vorne bringt es diese Debatte auch nicht für dich mal zusammenfassen, ne? Trotz alledem wär die Antwort des CCCs noch nicht gelesen hat, die äh finde ich zumindest äußerst unterhaltsam.
Dieser eine Begriff des Prädigitalen Analphabeten oder wie hieß?
Predigitale Ignoranten mit Rechte verwertungsfetisch.
Sehr gut, dann meine.
Ist schon sehr unterhaltsam.
Kann man sich mal durchles.
Gibt's auf jeden Fall ein Sternchen dafür.
Und wird auch nochmal interessant.
Wenn die einundfünfzig Hacker ja nicht unterzeichnet haben, ja? Also wo die jetzt sind, ist mir nicht so ganz klar.
Ich weiß aber, dass die diesen Text zumindest kollaborativ geschrieben haben in einem IFA-Pet, ja. Das kann das kann ich also äh.
Es waren genau einundfünfzig, ja.
Wäre cool gewesen, wenn sie einfach ihren Auftrag Isar Pet und das ist der Name, wer auch überall.
Also die haben sich auf jeden Fall ähm im Gegensatz zu dem,
zu den äh zu dem Text der einundfünfzig Tatortautoren äh ist es so, dass dieser CCC-Text tatsächlich kollaborativ entstanden ist und da auch einer ähm internen Debatte,
äh sich stellen musste.
Ja, kommen wir dann vielleicht zu unserem äh abschließenden äh Blick in die Zeit. So ein bisschen so den Eindruck irgendwie äh
Berichterstattung über die Piraten nimmt äh na ja Überhand ist vielleicht äh die falsche Bedeutung, aber hast du das Gefühl, die nächste Runde wurde eingeleitet
Nachdem sie ja jetzt äh äh nach Ewigkeiten hochgejubelt äh wurden und äh die Alternative und bla, bla, bla. Jetzt haben sie irgendwie zwei Landtagswahlen gewonnen. Jetzt wollen auf einmal alle wieder äh Ergebnisse sehen.
Ähm mangelt,
viel Freizeit. Also ich war äh im Urlaub letzte Woche, äh konnte ich nicht alles so so mitverfolgen, was vor allem auch so auf den Fernsehkanälen lief. Wie hat sich das euch so dargestellt?
Ja so für mich ist es schon ein Durchbruch und zwar wirklich das ist aus meiner,
Einschätzungen äh mit den Piraten als Phänomen ähm treten wir da so,
für die Bundesrepublik in eine neue Phase des politischen Systems ein.
Und das finde ich hochinteressant. Wir selbst in unserer Filter Bubble kennen die Piraten ja schon ganz lange oder es sind ja,
Viele Piraten kennen wir länger, als es die Piratenpartei gibt und äh,
Jetzt haben wir natürlich auch so einige äh Freunde und Bekannte an die Piraten verloren und äh.
An den Landtag.
Er, wobei man dann sagen muss, ähm äh das Land hat dafür gewonnen, auch so schmerzhaft das dann ist,
Und ich hätte das nicht nicht gedacht. Ich habe äh die äh Gründung der Piraten wirklich aus nächster Nähe mitbekommen auf der Visits of Ost zweitausendsechs,
Ich glaube, ich weiß nicht, ob das eine spontane Geschichte war, das aus so einer, aus so einer, so einer, dieser schwedischen Truppe, äh, sich dann so ein paar Leute, äh, in Berlin gesagt haben, das machen wir jetzt auch. Los, Piraten,
gründen uns und äh äh das weiß ich nicht genau, auf jeden Fall, es gab dann so eine Art Party in der Seabase, das habe ich auch noch so mitbekommen und das war ganz klar so APPD, Spaßpartei,
die haben das zwar schon selber ernst gemeint, aber der,
der öffentliche oder nach außen durchdringende Eindruck war, okay, das ist so ein, so ein, so ein Spaß-Projekt. Und das dümpelte dann ja auch vor sich hin und dann kam eben diese Zensur sogar im Moment,
mit auch den mit den interessanten Zwotausendneuner Bundestagswahlding und das hat ja 'ne unglaubliche.
Ein Ruck ging durch Deutschland.
Da ging Ruck durch Deutschland und ich bin so ein bisschen sauer auf die Wähler, warum sie jetzt die Piraten mit teilweise zwölf Prozent angeben,
Also was ist das für ein ein feiges Pack, dass sie sich nicht äh vor drei Jahren schon äh wenigstens mal mit drei Komma acht oder mit vier Komma acht oder fünf Komma acht Prozent bei den Piraten angemeldet haben, erst,
wo sie merken, ah, meine Stimme ist nicht verloren, ähm da setzen sie dann auf einmal drauf. Also äh das finde ich ja ganz interessant und,
dass die,
Piraten es wirklich geschafft haben, weil nach zwotausendneun, nach diesem diesem ersten Begeisterungssturm ähm war's dann ja schon ein bisschen zäh, die zwei Jahre. Also hat hättet ihr vor genau einem, das war vor einem Jahr, ne? Hättet ihr.
Eine namhafte Summe drauf gesetzt, dass die Piraten ins äh Landesparlament äh Berlin einziehen.
Nö, hätte ich nicht.
Hätte ich nämlich auch nicht.
Ganz klar.
Ja und die Wände kam mit dieser exzellenten Plakataktion und da war's dann wieder so, dass ich einfach auch selber vor mir sagen musste, äh,
sechs Plakatmotive und vier von den sechs Leuten kenne ich persönlich. Dieser Partei kann ich irgendwie nicht die Stimme verweigern.
Also ich kenne die persönlich, aber ich mag die dann auch. Also ich kenne ja auch, dass ich die alle persönlich kenne und so. Ähm,
Das ist halt auch ein äh und jetzt,
machen die einen Durchmarsch und äh äh die letzte Woche hat im Nachklang der äh der erfolgreichen Saarlandwahl äh ein vollkommen neues Level erreicht, denn,
Berliner Erfolg war immer noch unter.
Ja, Berlin und.
Dieser Möglichkeit, da gab's, da gab's mal die Republikaner und die äh die Grünalternative Liste oder AL, die waren immer schon erfolgreich, das konnte man so unter diesem Chaos äh Haufen Berlin irgendwie ab äh
tun, aber Saarland als so ein bisschen Zurückgebliebenes spätentwickeltes Bundesland.
Hinzugekommen, das Bundesland, genau.
Äh
äh das das hat also wirklich die die Sache geändert, bloß dass jetzt äh diese diese äh Zwischengeschobenen nicht im Terminkalender vorgesehenen Landtagswahlen dazukamen. Ähm ist natürlich eine neue Situation und für mich ist so,
dieser dass der Fokus und nicht der Spiegel, sondern der Fokus,
mit diesen hm Motiv, mit den momentan berühmtesten Piraten so aufgetaucht ist, die Marina Weißbank wirklich super zurechtgemacht,
mal ganz anders fotografiert als man sie sonst sieht. Richtig so Covergirl, Like plus noch äh,
so eine Mischung aus diabolischem Schalk und so einer Joschka Fischer, haftig Aura, äh der äh Christopher Lauer, also dieses Ding ist toll, weil ähm es,
Dieser Fokus spricht so dieses,
klassische Mittelschicht an, die immer auch so ein bisschen existenzangst hat. Ja, der Spiegel-Leser weiß mehr und er lässt sich so gerne ein bisschen kitzeln von irgendwelchen Shop-Nachrichten. Das belastet ihn nicht. Der Fokusleser, der braucht immer die tausend besten Ärzte,
hundert Top Rechtsanwälte für ihren Erfolg.
Das erinnert mich immer so an High Fidelity, wo die Jungs auch immer äh diese diese Toplisten für alles machen müssen. Es scheint so so ein Nick Horn-Befans zu sein, die da im Fokus lesen.
Ja, das sind die die Fokusleser sind letztlich äh sicherheitsbedürftige, hilfebedürftige Menschen und die brauchen Stabilität in ihrem äh anstrengenden Job. Und äh dass der Fokus gewissermaßen sagt,
Wir erklären das nicht nur, sondern wir sagen auch und zeigen diese Person auch im Sinne von, da ist eine neue Chance. Also das wird der ist,
Ich habe diesen Artikel nicht gelesen, aber was ich gehört habe, war, dass es kein Verriss ist und auch die äh Aufmachung äh schien mir äh,
relativ positiv, wie ich das schon besprochen habe. Und dann kam, glaube letzte Donnerstag, ich,
würde jetzt mal sagen, auch Piraten intern war das Peak Pirate, nämlich an einem Abend,
Vier Talkshows, zwei mit Christopher Lauer, eine mit und eine mit, glaube ich.
Kann das sein? Und ähm das war natürlich, die waren auch praktisch alle zur selben Zeit. Also man konnte über mehrere Kanäle.
Inzepte von Kanal zu Kanal und in Piraten zu Pirat.
Ja und es kam noch hinzu, war super, das war glaube ich Phönix, das war sehr sachlich. Ähm März war, glaube ich, bei Beckmann,
nicht genau, das war relativ äh entspannt. Der ist ja jetzt auch nicht so der der Volks äh Tribun. Aber Lauer war deswegen interessant, weil er einerseits,
in einer Late Now Late Night Show von Stuckrad-Barre einfach herumgekaspert hat und zwar absolut enpa. Also er hat der war,
Du jetzt irgendeinem Menschen aus dem Ausland erklärt, dass es Christopher Lauer hieße, Stand-up-Comedian und hier ist,
hätte jeder gesagt, oh, okay, deswegen albern die so rum.
Der hat also sich nicht verhalten, wie ein Politiker, sondern war genauso schnell mit all den zynischen Witzen und äh das,
so ein kleines Ding, das das für mich gezeigt hat, dass das sich einfach auch kommunikativ auf einer ganz anderen Welle,
lebt und nicht nur im Netz, sondern eben auch wirklich in der in der Darstellung hochinteressant und dann hat er der Christopher Lauer ja quasi bei Maybrit Illner den ähm Beck, den Ministerpräsidenten getreut und zwar in der in der Art,
Die war unglaublich,
weil er gar nicht viel gemacht hat. Und der Back äh war deswegen so ausm Häuschen, weil er äh auf zwei Ebenen herausgefordert wurde. Nicht nur als Politiker,
sondern er ist quasi der geheime Chef vom ZDF. Und das war sein Sender.
Und er kommt dann nach Berlin, wo sie ihn schon mal weggemobbt haben.
Äh äh normalerweise rastet der nicht so aus, aber äh der wurde gewissermaßen in zwei für ihn wichtigen Positionen von dem Lauer äh äh so dermaßen äh äh bedrängt, dass da eine äh wirklich ungute Situation entstanden ist und,
die dann wiederum der Christopher Lauer in einem FAZ-Artikel besprochen hat, dass er gesagt hat, das macht alles keinen Sinn mehr. Und das fand ich total spannend, dass er wirklich gesagt hat,
Wir sollten aus diesen Showveranstaltungen uns zurückziehen, weil äh ein ernsthafter politischer Dialog ist dort nicht mehr möglich. Und.
Das hat wer gesagt. Ja.
Christopher Lauer. Ja und das finde ich toll und ich würde die Piraten bestärken, äh äh aus diesen diesen äh Extremstandardisierten Formaten, Jauch, Will,
Beckmann, hat aber fair, äh äh,
Maybrit Illner, äh wie die alle heißen, rauszugehen und eher die kleinen Formate weiter hm zu äh die auch irgendwie ein bisschen seriöser sind, also Phönix Runde und sowas, das,
Da ist ein andere Dialogsituation oder eben wirklich in diese Spaß-Fraktionsgeschichten äh äh zu gehen, wie bei bei Stuttgart Barre.
Sag doch mal ganz kurz, was war jetzt irgendwie das äh das Problem? Der hat sich irgendwie mit Beck und da ging's um diese Schleckergeschichte, ne.
Die Sendetitel war Schuldenstaat,
Und äh dazu sagte Lauer, hätte ich auch was sagen können, weil er hatte sich nämlich vorher äh oder er dachte er wäre eingeladen worden, auch wegen seiner Kritik an dem Opernetat, den er zugunsten,
Möglicher, stärkerer Basiskulturförderung in Frage gestellt hat. Das ist letztlich auch eine ganz legitime Fragestellung.
Den Berliner Etat, ne?
Genau. Ist ja Landtagsabgeordneter und äh dann ging's aber wie immer äh politisch aktuell um die Schlepperfrauen und ihre Anschlussverwendungsfähigkeit und äh,
äh und,
Der Beck war wohl in so einer äh Ministerpräsidenten-Kumgel-Runde, die da versucht haben, in dieser Beteiligungsgesellschaft, Auffanggesellschaft, was zu machen. Und ähm,
Ja und äh der äh Christopher Lauer in seiner ganzen Art war eigentlich auch eigentlich A politisch unterwegs, weil er eigentlich immer nur doch eher gestört hat. Das war eher der Tonfall, als das, was er gesagt hat.
Mhm. Und das ist ja bei ihm häufig so.
Ja ja, das ist aber äh aber dieses dieses Getrolle innerhalb dieses,
verkrusteten Systems, wenn für dich großartig, weil er äh er kann trollen, weil er eine andere Position hat. Wenn das jetzt irgendwie so ein Schauspieler, so ein durchgekokster wäre, der das genauso macht, dann würden alle sagen, das ist ein Kasper.
Hm, aber er ist.
Er ist kein Kasper, weil er ist der er ist Landtagsabgeordneter. Er hat eine politische Bedeutung und äh damit kommen die nicht zurecht.
Er ist vor allem der, das war das wahrnehmbarste und bekannteste Gesicht der Piraten.
Zusammen mit Marina Weißband derzeit, die sich da so ein bisschen eine andere Rolle spielt.
Mit Marina Weißband, ja, die aber irgendwie eher äh leider in eine andere Rolle auch wahrscheinlich gepresst wird.
Ja, aber da hat sie sich auch ganz gut. Also die ist auch eine extrem charismatische, interessante äh Figur.
Direkt vergleichen. Sie war ja auch bei Stuckradbach.
Ich habe ich habe keinen Fernseher, deswegen, ich kann das alles gar nicht. Mediathek, da muss ich mal Mediathek gucken. So, aber jetzt also jetzt sind die alle im Fernsehen und ähm was jetzt?
Ne, die haben gemerkt, sie kommen gar nicht. Das ging das System in diesen öffentlich-rechtlichen Anstalten ist so verkrustet und letztlich mit diesem Staatssystem gegen das wir reformieren wollen, eigentlich in einer gewissen Weise so äh,
So verwoben, dass äh,
die das gar keine richtige äh Diskussionskultur mehr möglich ist. Und die Piraten haben momentan eigentlich den Drive wirklich zu sagen, wir machen den Quatsch nicht mehr mit,
Wir äh äh wir gehen da nicht mehr hin. Das finde ich.
Also das wäre ja, das wäre ja sehr spannend, weil ich meine, sie hatten ja wirklich, also ich habe das Problem, ehrlich gesagt, sehr viel früher schon äh irgendwie.
Warte mal, wir wir gehen wo nicht mehr hin? In Talkshows, ins Fernsehen an sich, nur in diese Kasperrunden jetzt.
In diese hochformalisierten
Kasperrunden, wo kein äh wirklicher Dialog mehr möglich ist und auch der Lauer wiederum, das fand ich toll. Er hat gesagt, ich habe ja gesehen, welche Fragen sie vorbereitet hatte, die Maybrit Illner. Aber die hat dann vollkommen angefangen, frei zu drehen und zu improvisieren.
Ja gut, das kann er ja jetzt nicht zum Vorwurf machen.
Doch, er kann doch sagen, ich bin eingeladen worden, äh zu einem bestimmten Thema. Äh ich opfere meinen meinen Abend äh äh soll was zur Landes, zu meiner Landespolitischen.
Bereitet man sich ja auch drauf vor.
Ja und dann komm auf ab, wird er mit Schleckerfrauen äh quasi äh äh konfrontiert, wo er sich überhaupt nicht drauf vorbereitet hat,
Er wieder dasteht, ja, der typische Pirat hat wieder keine Ahnung,
Tage später hat er dann gesagt, was sind elftausend Arbeitslose Schleckerfrauen gegenüber den so und so vielen Millionen, die sich jedes Jahr arbeitslos melden bei der Agentur für Arbeit. Die fallen ja nicht ins Nichts, ne.
Also auch diese diese Standardisierten ritualisierten Formen von Erregungs,
äh Merkmalen, die da in diesen Talkrunden aufgerufen werden und vollkommen beim Thema vorbeigehen, zu sagen, gibt's,
Steckerfrauen sicherlich ein Problem, aber es gibt doch die.
Ist erstmal der Begriff, den finde ich schon unmöglich.
Wer mehr Schleckerfrauen.
Anschlussverwendung für Schleckerfrauen, also dass das hat mich äh da konnte ich mich noch nicht mal mehr darüber aufregen, so so entlarvend wie diese Begriffe waren. Aber jetzt trotzdem nochmal ähm,
Eigentlich kann doch Christopher Lauer glänzt doch grade in diesen Formaten. Ja, also ist doch unvergessen irgendwie seinen Auftritt. Da äh Bärbel Höhn äh bei Anne Will, wie so, also gerade.
Ja gut, aber äh aber man macht.
Diesen Formaten glänzt er doch, wenn alle anderen nämlich irgendwie mit ihren vorgefertigten ähm Phrasen kommen und die da.
Aber dass jemand glänzt, ist das eine, dass man jetzt wirklich in so einem Diskurs, ich meine, das ist ja vielleicht eine extrem überhöhte Erwartung an so ein Format, ja, aber
Wäre es nicht schön, wenn man mal in der Diskussion auch wirklich zu Ergebnissen käme, ja, warum macht man das? Warum in.
Doch das ist ja.
Das eigentlich nichts anderes ist als politisches Schlammketschen. Es geht einfach dadrum, dass die Leute sehen wollen, dass da jemand auf der Fresse landet und sie ordentlich
das Hemd braun macht und, und, und, und, und dann haben irgendwie alle ihren Spaß gehabt, ja, weil es egal, wie jetzt der Griff angesetzt wurde.
Politsimulation eigentlich äh betrieben wird. Und das seit vielen Jahren. Ich habe das Gefühl,
Endlich besteht mal die Chance, diese diese seit zwanzig Jahren aufkommende Polit-Simulation in diesen öffentlichen äh äh Runden zu durchbrechen und äh äh
begrüßenswert, wenn die Piraten sagen würden, wer uns zuhören will, soll doch einfach das Parlamentsfernsehen gucken, wir trollen dort schon ausreichend.
Ja, aber das tun sie.
Ich sage ich sage nur von der Palme wedeln, ne.
Ja ja.
Letztens zur äh also das ist,
Das würde quasi eine Reparlamentarisierung bedeuten und ich finde, die Piraten haben Momente das Momentum einfach äh äh ihrem quasi System verändernden Ansatz. Das finde ich ganz interessant, dass sie auch,
Meines Erachtens, die einzige Partei sind die äh wirklich nicht scheu zu sagen, wir wollen das System verändern. Und sie haben vor allen Dingen auch die die Möglichkeiten und sie haben auch äh
in bestimmten Bereichen, dass du auch schon inhaltlich ähm kanalisiert und äh ich finde das äh absolut großartig und ähm,
Ja, ich glaube, dass äh das etwas ist, was jetzt wirklich auch dazu führt, dass die ähm,
Altparteien, das ist ein bisschen blöder Begriff, weil äh oder die etablierten Parteien jetzt.
Prümlichen, herkömmlichen.
Partei.
Die konventionellen Partei.
Waschmittel und.
Dass die jetzt wirklich in in Panik geraten.
Und Internetvereine gründen.
Ja und vor allen Dingen, weil sie wissen, wenn die Piraten weitermachen und das ändern, dann sind sie die herkömmlichen Parteien in jedem Fall nicht mehr systemrelevant.
Denn das Tolle an den an den Piraten ist die berufen sich auf das Grundgesetz und da steht eben nur drin, die Parteien wirken an der Willensbildung mit,
Auswüchse des Parteienstaats. Das ist so wie Flash, das sich aufgesetzt hat, ja. Ich sehe eine Person jetzt hier so ein bisschen lachen,
Ja? Und die Piraten sehe ich so ein bisschen als Flashblocker, die uns quasi zeigen, äh wie durchseucht eigentlich unser System ist,
ähm indem entsprechend jetzt überall so ein kleiner Fleck äh mal gemacht wird, weil Koalitionsausschuss. Ähm die wie der Parteienstaat, die das öffentlich-rechtliche äh Fernsehen durchdrungen hat, da war dieser Backmoment für
für mich sehr interessant, weil äh.
Weil das sich auch so auf der politischen Ebene total äh Proports genau äh austariert wird und das nicht also das ist nicht Staatsfern, sondern das ist Parastaatlich
Ja, wie im Paramilitär. Und äh äh,
Das finde ich äh großartig und ich sehe da wirklich ein revolutionären Moment und ich kann die Piraten nur äh ermuntern, jetzt bei der Stange zu bleiben, weil das wird jetzt richtig heftig.
Also du würdest jetzt, weil du sagtest grade äh ich will da nochmal drauf zurückkommen. Also die Piraten haben jetzt oder du sagst, die Piraten erkennen jetzt, dass sie,
Ähm dass dieser Medien, diese Medienauftritte irgendwie wie so sagen wir wie so eine gefährliche,
wie das giftige Gewächs sind
was irgendwie jedes Mal irgendwie gut zündet und irgendwie Spaß macht, aber letztendlich vielleicht irgendwie ihre Partei oder Politikkultur, ähm für die sie irgendwann mal mit Überzeugung angetreten sind. Ähm
irgendwie ein bisschen entgleiten lässt. Und deswegen sagen sie, ähm okay, nein, wir stehen wirklich für den
nicht für den Marsch in die Institution oder durch die Institution, sondern für die Veränderung der Institutionen durch ihre Unterwanderung und den die wirkliche nachhaltige Beeinflussung des politischen
Systemes weniger als seiner Ergebnisse.
Der Anspruch war ja schon bei den Grünen. Ja, ein Basisdemokratie, Imperatives Mandat, Rotation, all das ist gescheitert, weil sie nicht die Tools hatten. Die Piraten als,
netzaffine Partei haben diese Tool, ich glaube so was wie äh wie. Diese Art und Weise wie momentan mit allen Instrumenten, die wir auch schon alle seit Jahren nutzen, die aber in den in den groß,
äh und äh Strukturen und den bürokratischen Institutionen des politischen Apparats überhaupt noch nicht durchgedrungen sind, das wird denen eine,
Effektivität verschaffen, die Piraten sind wirklich wie diese somalischen Schlauchboot äh äh Piraten, die quasi um die Supertanker Kreise drehen. Und äh äh,
Und mit der Strickleiter hochklettern.
Ja, aber auch manchmal äh dann doch auch mal ordentlich eins auf die Mütze bekommen, ne. Also ich ich teile viel von dem äh äh was du sagst. Ich würde jetzt mal sagen, es ist eine sehr optimistische Sicht auf die Dinge. Ähm auf der anderen Seite die Empire Strikes äh äh Back und
wir haben ja jetzt hier im wahrsten Sinne des Wortes.
FTM mit E, ja?
Ähm ich bin mir noch nicht so so richtig sicher, ich habe jetzt auch, wie gesagt, die äh äh letzten Beiträge alle noch nicht nachgeschaut,
Auf der einen Seite muss man sich auch nichts vormachen. Die Medien,
die Piraten derzeit auch deshalb auf, weil's einfach eine geile Story ist. So, ja und sie pumpen sie jetzt in ihre Kanäle rein und sie haben gesehen, ah, alles klar, wir haben da jetzt hier irgendwie einen schönen
super Politkaspar da am Start, der ordentlich austeilen kann, der irgendwie vom Comedyformat bis zur äh
ne? Äh bis zur Talkrunde äh wunderbar passt und äh ja, dann haben wir noch das Mädel und äh jetzt suchen sie händeringend noch nach äh nach dem dritten oder vierten, der auch noch ganz gut äh tun würde, weil die sind halt schon alle ein bisschen überbucht,
äh und und machen sich da halt einfach ihre Stars. Normalerweise läuft's dann einfach so
In dem Moment, wo sie dann das Feld auch äh gesichtet haben und wissen, womit sie wedeln können, dann beginnt dann eben auch der nächste Teil. Und dann
Äh das sehe ich halt in Ansätzen auch schon, ne, so hier. Da werden dann immer so dieses Stückchen vorgehalten. Da gab's auch wiederum schön äh gekontert von äh äh Christopher Lauer, fand ich zumindest, weiß ich jetzt gar nicht, wer war das Tagesspiel
piel, weil das auch der Fokus dieses Telefoninterview dann auch mal so ja hier zum.
NTV, ne?
N-tv, genau, ja
ja, also hier so zwölf Prozent und äh ja was was machen sie denn, wenn sie da mal in einer Koalition sind und so weiter, also es äh er hat das sehr geschickt gemacht, er ist da nicht auf Stöckchen getreten, ne, aber auf jeden Fall die Lunte wird da schon mal ausgelegt äh um jetzt einfach mal zu sehen, so ah jetzt hier, jetzt lassen wir es auch mal schön ins offene Messer laufen
Es wird sehr interessant äh äh sein zu sehen, ob die,
Tools, die du da erwähnt hast, ja, die offene Kommunikation, so diese diese Schnellalarmsysteme über Twitter et cetera, ausreichen werden, um da alle, die von den Piraten in die Öffentlichkeit geschickt werden oder gezogen werden, ähm
ausreichend dazu brief mich erneut es auch sehr an die Zeit, wo ich auch sagen wir mal so der Öffentlichkeitsarbeit
Clubs noch ein bisschen näher äh äh stand und äh wo man auch immer wieder so mitbekommen hat, ne? Äh äh wie man sich da eben auch ähm zu wehren hat und welche äh welche Tricks da gefahren werden seitens der Medien. Also das ist auf jeden Fall,
Punkt.
Ja, aber ich sehe doch noch eine Gesellschaftliche Veränderung. Ähm,
auf die auch Linos gestern Stall gegangen ist und mich deswegen eingeladen hat, nämlich das ist ein bisschen so eine Art,
Milch, das ist schon Milieu ist, das in den Piraten sich widerspiegelt. Milieu, dem wir uns sicherlich auch nah,
oder zugehörig fühlen können. Und zwar Leute, die an ganz unterschiedlichen Stellen in der Gesellschaft,
Diejenigen sind, die im Maschinenraum äh unseres heutigen hochtechnisierten äh äh Gemeinwesens arbeiten.
Und äh von daher auch eine gute Aussicht haben darauf, was die Kasper auf der Brücke
eigentlich an Null-Peilung haben und an Phrasendrescherei betreiben. Und in dem Moment, da war der Zensursula äh äh konflikt genau ausschlaggebend.
Hatten diese Leute, die gewissermaßen mit der Ölkanne und Pelzmütze aufm Kopf, die Erdachse ölen, das Gefühl, äh jetzt verarschen sie uns aber. Jetzt,
Wir sorgen dafür, dass euer Scheiß-Laden läuft und jetzt nimmt ihr uns auch noch das Internet weg,
Das Einzige, was wir im Heizungskeller irgendwie haben, um Spaß zu haben. Da mischt ihr euch jetzt auch noch ein. Jetzt langt's. Und das vergleiche ich so ein bisschen mit der Arbeiterbewegung des neunzehnten Jahrhunderts,
wo quasi die ehemaligen Bauern, die poperisierten Massen alle in die Fabrik äh äh
abgeschoben worden sind. Sie hatten dann auf einmal nicht mehr ihre normale äh Grunderwerb. Sie hatten keine Pacht mehr, sie hatten äh nicht mehr,
und waren also auf Gedeih und Verderb in diesem neuen äh Maschinen- und Kapitalistischen System drin und haben,
das aber auch mit einem großen Etos vertreten
und haben dann gesagt, also wir sind doch diejenigen, die diese Maschinen hier alle am Laufen halten. Und da kommt jetzt irgendeine traditionelle Herrscherklicke, äh äh der Patron
führt einen fünftausend Menschenunternehmen wie seine fünf äh Mannwerkstatt. So geht's nicht mehr weiter. Und äh ich vergleiche diesen,
Diesen Aufbruch der IT-Arbeiterschaft, ja? Äh wie er sich ja auch äh momentan in der Zugehörigkeit bei den, bei den Leuten äh in äh bei den Abgeordneten auch nach wie vor in den Paraden.
Ja, er zeigt als eine äh ganz fantastische,
fantastische Geschichte, weil äh die sich quasi jetzt äh gesellschaftliche Legitimation und Partizipation wieder aneignen, die ihnen verloren gegangen ist. Und dieses bestehende,
System erscheint mir hohl,
Und deswegen glaube ich, dass äh die Piraten wirklich eine große Chance haben, äh äh dieses System,
wirklich grundlegend zu verändern, weil bis zu einem Drittel der äh äh Gesellschaft, vielleicht sogar vierzig Prozent aus meiner Sicht äh und vor allen Dingen die aktive Gesellschaft, ja, der Fokus-Leser. Äh äh schon,
in dieser Welt auch leben und sich von den Piraten wirklich effektiv auch in ihrer Lebens- und Arbeitswelt vertreten fühlen,
Und äh das ist etwas, was äh ich
für für ganz enorm halte. Und das ist nochmal ein Unterschied zu dieser äh grünen Bewegung, die war doch wesentlich enger. Das waren die Lehrer, das waren die Studenten, das waren die die extra die äh,
aber die hatten quasi auch teilweise viel größere Schutzräume wie die Universitäten und äh in dem Moment, wo sie Karriere gemacht haben,
haben sie sich dann ja auch stark verbürgerlich, aber die Piraten sind halt schon für Bürgerlicht.
Piraten gegen die Hohlwelt. Das ganze Szenario erzeugt mehr Titel, als man Podcasts machen kann. Ähm ja.
Ich würde ja trotzdem noch kurz abschließend äh noch ein Statement äh einholen. Ähm wenn du jetzt das Peak Pirate, was was heißt, also ein mediales nur. Okay, ein mediales.
Zwar von den Piraten selber gewissermaßen so gefühlt ist, dass so kann's nicht weitergehen.
Okay? Ja, ja, okay, also das wollte ich nur wissen, ob du oder ob du jetzt quasi das das Bundesrepublik politische äh das wäre jetzt.
Spiegel hat es gestern quasi an die Wand gemalt, dass sie gesagt haben, die Piraten haben jetzt Angst vorm eigenen Erfolg,
Ja, dass ein paar Sachen, wir wollen keine Volkspartei, wir wollen nicht regieren, wir wollen lieber in unserer kleinen Nische bleiben. Also der Begriff, den kann man durchaus ambivalent auf die medialen äh Overkill, aber auch vielleicht als,
hinzumessen auf die eigene Piratenangst, die wählen uns ja wirklich, wie lauer auf seinem Plakat. Äh,
geschrieben hatte.
Ja, so viel äh zur Piratenpartei.
Genau und so viel eigentlich auch äh zum Netz politischen äh Geschehen hier. Eine etwas längere äh Ausgabe, damit der die Osterfeiertage ja auch äh äh ordentlich absitzen könnt.
Ja und wir wollten halt nochmal einmal einen längeren Piratenabschnitt haben äh bevor Piek Pirate ja und man damit keine keine Hörer mehr generiert, Piraten Content,
zieht gerade.
Genau, da mussten wir einfach äh mitmachen, ja. Auch wir sind den Gesetzen der Medienwelt hier unterworfen. Absolut. Ne?
Schwimmen mit. Ähm bringt mich so ein bisschen auf, sag mal, sind wir eigentlich schon soweit, dass wir auch irgendwann mal hier so ein, so ein, so ein Veranstaltungskalender äh mit einbauen können, äh so als Ausblick oder äh ist das etwas, woran wir noch arbeiten müssen.
Ich glaube, da haben wir doch die Erfahrung gemacht, dass wir doch dann öfter mal noch kurzfristig eine Sendung verschieben mussten, oder? Also.
Nee, nicht für unsere eigene Sendung, sondern was so für äh Veranstaltungen, die vielleicht von Interesse sein können.
Jetzt die Pist die Pistole auf die Brust, die Pistole, auf die Brust.
Nö, sag einfach, du weißt es gerade nicht und dann sparen wir uns das für die nächsten Sendungen auf, aber ich wollte das vielleicht mal anregen, vielleicht könnt ihr euch da auch mal dazu äußern. Überhaupt, wenn ihr äh Vorschläge und Anregungen.
Wäre die Idee, die Tim jetzt gerade Ansprache wäre, quasi ein ein Kalender ähm mit netzpolitisch relevanten Terminen. Ne? Das ist das.
Ja, aber ich wollte jetzt weniger auf so eine elektronische äh abonnierbare Lösung aus, als dass wir vielleicht äh gegen Ende der Sendung einfach mal auch mal so einen Ausblick
wagen, was denn so an äh Veranstaltungen sich abzeichnet, weil auf der einen Seite reagieren wir auf Geschehenes, auf der anderen Seite äh äh könnte man ja äh es gibt das Lok,
ja, das äh füllen wir hier auch gerne aus, aber äh sich gegen Ende auch mal in den Ausguck zu begeben
in die Zukunft zu schauen. Ich meine, das haben wir jetzt hier mit äh Hilfe auch ein bisschen äh getan, zumindest die Gegenwart nochmal ähm intensiver beleuchtet.
Mir einfach vorstellen, dass wir hier unser Format noch ein bisschen entwickelt bekommen. Ansonsten sind wir für alle Vorschläge und Rückmeldungen immer dankbar,
auch wenn euch irgendwelche Themen auffallen, die ihr meint, die es wert werden, hier behandelt zu werden, dann reicht in der Regel ein kurzer Tweet schon aus.
Unterstrich Netzpolitik aber sonst noch was hinzuzufügen.
Seid ihr nächste Woche wieder auf Sendung?
Dann war's das. Tschüss.
Ciao ciao. Ciao.
Ciao.